[Music]
I walk into a room and I tell someone
I'm a glaciologist and usually someone
looks at me and says we'll soon you'll
be a historian because the ice is going
away we have the ability to turn this
around and I think we're going to we
just have to start moving in that
direction now the more we know about ice
the more we can get on board saving it
my name is M Jackson and I'm a
geographer and glaciologist and National
Geographic Explorer we have got great
data that saying the majority the ice
worldwide is melting it's responding to
climate change with negative mass
balance there's a lot of different
mechanisms but very generally we can say
our temperatures are getting warm that's
having a negative effect on the ice and
the ice is getting smaller the work I do
really tries to address the question
what's gonna happen as the world's ice
melts embedded in that question is what
can we do
so that's why I work along this pool
south coast of Iceland region the
largest ice cap in Iceland and all of
Europe that neo gold is right here
hundreds of years ago wouldn't say I
don't know the Taj Mahal was being built
it was snowing here and that snow was
turning into glacial ice okay so when
you're looking this what you're looking
is snow that fell hundreds of years ago
and the town of Huck is located where
all of these glaciers drain down and so
we can see the town right here and then
you have all of these different glaciers
that are draining down into the lagoons
that surround huh and what we see here
is that there's a lot of complex
physical impacts of glacier melt and
there's a lot of social impacts of
glacier mountain
whenever we want to visualize sea level
rise and glacier melt oftentimes we are
removing all the variables and we are
just visualizing if all the oceans rose
ten feet 100 feet 200 feet in a way that
usually looks is it's a uniform but that
doesn't take into account geography
places where maybe the land is subsiding
into the ocean or places that are
marshes or a really important one for
anywhere that there are glaciers land
that is rising up it's rebounding we see
a huge change happening in the harbor so
if you imagining at hand
a sponge and you press that sponge down
when you take your hand away that sponge
is gonna just spring right on back up
that is what is happening here all of
this ice that's here it pressed the
Earth's crust down it pressed the island
of Iceland down and so today as that ice
is melting away the land is springing
back up this is called isostatic rebound
glacial rebound these little islands
that are springing up that's really
great for the town they pop a house
right on their town got bigger but what
about the fishing
fishings a huge part of the Icelandic
economy but there's just this one harbor
in this whole area that's getting
shallower and shallower and shallower
boats have to sit outside of the Harper
and wait for high tide
what's gonna happen with dispatching
plan what's gonna happen to the biggest
industry in this industry I look at all
of that physical geography aspects of
ice and I add all the social aspects we
put it together we get a whole picture
of what's happening
the oceans are so so vast but they are
often controlled and shaped by cliches
so if you are standing looking at your
coastline during our last ice age the
ocean was about 400 feet lower than it
is today that's because those glaciers
they held more of that water in the form
of ice the flip side of that is today
those glaciers they're melting and
they're releasing
it is the nature of a glacier to melt
through preachers are always melting
they've always melted wrote history but
what is so different today is the phrase
enough never in human history have we
ever seen glaciers melt as quickly as
air melt even today
and that's gonna make the sea levels
rise so how do you get connected to
these glaciers if you're living say in
New Jersey or you're living in Florida
or Washington State there's gonna be
more precipitation which means in some
places or snow or in other places more
rain which means more volume in our
rivers in our lakes and our marshes the
more I started to study glaciers the
more people would ask many questions
that placed that glacier in a context of
people I started to have to have
conversations about fish I started to
have to have conversations about forests
and sheep I'd have conversations about
rivers shifting I can look at how people
understand what is happening here the
ice today and I'm able then to
understand how do people respond to
change so many of the young people that
I work with they are
yes climate change is happening yes the
glaciers are melting and yes I
individually have the power to effect a
positive change out of that it excites
me I will totally be honest with you it
really really does excite me climate
change is really really hard so I work
with young people and it reinterred
eise's me and it makes me excited and
off like stomp back out in the field
reenergized
I love I love being out on glaciers I
really do think that if we lose our ice
we lose something of our humanity we're
gonna lose a part of who we are if we
take away those places where we say
where we say or more importantly where
we don't see anything at all
because we're just so blown away
you
[Music]